I'd say the thing he should be doing
here in severe turbulence is just to fly
the plane you wouldn't start going on
the radio reporting severe turbulence to
your traffic control like what are they
gonna do about it you can tell them in
ten minutes what's going on doing it
while flying that rough air totally
unrealistic hello everyone my name is
Victor force commercial airline pilots
and this is the breakdown first up we
got Pargo so the man we can see down
there is the ground dispatcher or the
ground crew also called a Marshall er he
has normally contact with a headset to
the captain and he's making sure that
the engines are clear for start-up and
also that we're not pushing back into a
bad area towards an aircraft or
something like that in this scene they
are not connected by headset but we're
actually using hand signals typical hand
signal would be are we clear to start
engine number two it could also be
Chuck's removed or chucks in place
release the brakes set the parking brake
stuff like that so we have different
sign language to communicate with our
ground staff so this is a really nice
scene to see the interaction between the
pilots and the air traffic controllers
at the tower in this case you can hear
the pilots requesting taxi the air
traffic controller is telling him you're
number two for departure and you can see
he's moving those small strips airplanes
for taxi in one column aircrafts for
takeoff in another and landing traffic
in another so as you go along they're
moving you across that table just to
have everything in order but this system
is kind of old-school
the most common thing today at modern
airports is electronic flight strips
normally an airplane is parked at the
stand at the terminal where you enter as
a passenger from there they need to push
back the airplanes and start the engines
this is done with the help of a tug
which is a small car that is connected
to the nose wheel of the airplane it's
just pushing you backwards
and turn you in the direction where you
want it taxi you can see the captain
there advancing those thrust levers to
commands taxis so he's just spooling up
the engines to get that momentum and
start rolling
so here you can see the beautiful Boeing
747 the queen of the skies and the jumbo
jet when you're taxing on the ground of
an airport it's normal to taxi at a
speed around 30 knots which is more or
less 35 miles an hour
you'll taxi at that speed all the way up
to the runway and you report ready for
takeoff to the tower plus perfect
picture of a tug this is a tug and the
tow bar connected to an airplane pushing
it back just like every other airplane
for the pushback face
Swissair 363 you are cleared for takeoff
it's a 363 cleared to take off
once again you can hear that perfect
symphony between air traffic control and
the pilots he's telling them Swiss air
one two three you're now clear for
takeoff the pilots then read back we are
now clear for takeoff and then they can
just take a thrust and go
I've never been chasing anyone down the
runway but if I were to do that I
wouldn't drive just behind the engine
where the jet blasts comes out it's
super super hot and it blows around
hundred miles an hour you just wouldn't
do that so that's quite unrealistic so
in this movie obviously these guys
chasing the airplane down the runway are
police or military or something like
that in real life you wouldn't just be
able to enter the runway first of all
you need a clearance from the tower once
again to move on the maneuver area of an
airport and if this would to happen the
air traffic controllers would see it
straight away and try to contact you and
stop you or whatever
this is just hilarious an airplane this
size they have a rotation speed where do
you start to pick up the airplane for
takeoff around hundred and sixty knots
that's 185 miles an hour
I really doubt those old trucks and
police cars can catch up with an
airplane at 185 miles an hour they would
be long gone and the airplane would just
accelerate pasta we got wheels up wait
ladies and gentlemen it is our pleasure
to announce that alcoholic beverages are
now very all companies they work
differently and have different piece
standard operating procedures but
normally when you have done your initial
turn after take off and you're at the
safe altitude and you don't expect any
turbulence you just ding the cabin car
in the roof and they know that they can
start the service and start walking in
the aisle and a few minutes later the
pilots will release all the passengers
next up we have one of my favorite
movies catch me if you can what are you
my dad head to Miami yes yes okay this
is hilarious all pilots out there know
what deadhead or deadheading means it's
basically a cabin crew or a pilot
positioning for duty so every time
you're on board an airplane as a
passenger and you see a pilot or a cabin
crew in full uniform but sitting down
not working there most probably dead
heading dead heading to the destination
to operate another flight I absolutely
love this scene because he has no idea
what he's doing but he still does it and
the dead you're a little late but the
jump seat is open it's been a while
since I've done this which ones the jump
seat again the jump seat is another
thing everybody knows what it is it's
those small foldable seats we have in
the cabin for cabin crew but also in the
flight deck for extra pilots traveling
you turning around on the red-eye jump
in puddles for the next few months Ryan
might keep running leapfrog to the weak
and weary
no shame in that I'm jumping puddles
like what he probably means that he's
flying short halt and it's super busy
just to earn that extra buck in the end
of the month he is now in the flight
deck saying hi to the guys there and
he's looking for that jump seat
obviously has no idea where it is I
wouldn't either like I've never flown
this aircraft type the jump seat is
placed in different places and hidden
around on all airplanes okay that's a
really small jump seat I wouldn't like
to sit on that for many hours in the
airplane I fly it's a bit bigger it's
still hidden
kind of you wouldn't find it if you
don't know where it is but it's
definitely a lot more sturdy and you
have full straps four-point straps and
you'll feel safe so this is obviously a
few years back and they still had a
flight engineer back then some airplanes
even had a communicator only managing
the radio but today in modern aircraft
we have computers watching out for all
the systems and they're just going to
alert the flight crew if they find any
faults or system failures on board the
airplane it's probably just a matter of
time before the computers take my job as
well and kick me out of that flight day
[Music]
so this is a normal day at work you
start your take-up run come to 80 knots
and the pilot monitoring will always say
80 knots that's to double check that the
other pilot is not incapacitated we also
check that the speed indicators on both
displays are showing the same then we
reach another speed which is called v1
which is the decision speed if something
happens before b1 we can still abort the
takeoff and brake and stop but after
reaching the speed of v1 whatever
happens we kind of need to continue and
then we'll just solve the problem in the
air and probably get back to land on the
same runway later on rotate is obviously
when the pilots starting rotate the
aircraft up to get that pitch attitude
for liftoff and climbed away from the
ground dear dad today was graduation I
am now a co-pilot earning $1400 a month
plus benefits and the best part is they
tell me my family can fly for free we
travel for all your family I wish I had
that it's not necessarily true for all
pilots around the world but we have some
benefits with our job though like the
whole world is our playground and we can
kind of go work anywhere deadheading and
jump seating is always for free enjoying
your free ride back in the 60s pilots
had quite a lot of status in society but
today it's not really like that links
between cabin crew and pilots it does
happen like my girlfriend she's a pilot
just like me we didn't meet like this or
on a layover but we're in the same
business and we're together so would you
be able to dress up as a pilot put on a
smile and just expect a free ride to
Miami
no it's not that simple anymore maybe
back in the 60s they didn't have these
extensive checks but all airline pilots
today have a company ID saying who you
are where you're from what airline you
fly for you need to have a passport as
well and a flying license it checks are
much more extensive nowadays to let a
pilot on board your plane and take him
deadheading somewhere else moving on to
snakes on a plane
so the cabin crew is entering that
flight day the pilots are obviously
nodding their seats killed by snakes or
whatever the airplane is just in a dive
straight towards the ground this
wouldn't happen in real life because at
that cruising altitude you would always
by law fly with an autopilot if the
pilots would be incapacitated the
airplane would just continue level
flight as far as you have fuel for it so
as long as you have fuel on board it
will just keep that altitude and nothing
else will happen autopilot is a
fantastic tool to have on board the
airplane it reduces the workload for
both pilots enormous Lee and we can even
relax you know take a nap during flight
a lot of passengers and travellers out
there they are not aware that we
actually can sleep during the flight
it's called controlled rest and we have
really strict rules and regulations when
we can do it and when we can't do it we
can only sleep one at a time that's very
important but even though we have the
autopilot and it reduces our workload we
cannot just leave our seats like in this
clip one pilot always needs to be there
to guard the controls and monitor or
whatever happens
so here you can see the airplane flying
the literally inside a thunderstorm
it's just lightning everywhere and
that's obviously Hollywood doing it more
exciting for the Watchers it wouldn't
happen like this in real life we
wouldn't just fly in darkness straight
into the thunderstorms
they don't have pilots at the moment but
even before you can kind of see with the
weather radar thunderstorms up to 160
miles ahead of you so you would take
avoidance actions pretty early to avoid
thunderstorms even if you're hit by
lightning it's not the worst thing that
could happen to you because the
airplanes fuselage would just act as a
paradise cage and the lightning will
just go straight through you it could
damage your hair planes a bit in worst
case scenarios but you should be safe we
as pilots we don't really need to see
any lights because we only fly on our
instruments most commercial flights out
there today are following IFR rules
it means instrument flight rules so we
don't need any external references to
fly from A to B it can actually complete
darkness or fog or whatever and they can
even land in zero visibility
[Music]
this is serious business she's reaching
for the axe and yes we do have a crash
axe in most airplanes today in the
airplane I fly the Boeing 737 we have a
crash act just like this in the flight
deck it's used to access electrical
fires behind panels in the passenger
cabin you use that axe to hatch true and
then you can use the fire extinguisher
to put out the fire
so this is quite realistic to enter the
flight pick today from the passenger
cabin you need to have emergency access
code to type in that will unlock the
door but the pilots can still decide to
deny that access because if someone
wants to interfere with the flight or
hijack you even if they managed to get
the code from one of the stewardesses we
as pilots can still deny them to enter
the flight deck access code is different
for all airplanes and it also changes
with the set time interval
time to strap in just pull up pull up
pull hard that's not really how it works
I mean these are hydraulically operated
servos that controlling this airplane it
wouldn't be hard to pull it up you would
just like gently pull it backwards like
a small six-year-old could probably do
it it wouldn't be this dramatic either
[Music]
and this airplane as you can see in the
passenger cabin has spiral steps to the
second floor it's actually the same
airplane the Boeing 747 as we saw before
in the Argo clip you have two floors two
at the front and one in the back and the
pilots are situated at the front the
second floor the Boeing 747 is the
second largest passenger airplane in the
world they can carry up to four hundred
and sixty-seven passengers which is
quite a lot and I would wonder how that
would see if they bring all those passes
you're up to the first floor that would
be pretty packed up next Sully
one of the best aviation movies out
there today it's so incredibly well done
I just love the movie it's actually made
by listening to the real voice recorders
of that crash captain Sullenberger and
the first officer that did a magnificent
job let's watch it birds
this is a really nasty scenario with a
lot of birds but engines out there on
modern aircrafts are actually designed
by the manufacturer to withstand some
extent of bird strikes in the testing
phase of the engines they actually shoot
frozen birds through the engines just to
see how they react and they have to
withstand these forces and be able to
continue flying to go through the
certification process but obviously not
this many births so I'm not surprised
they're not able to fly anymore in front
of the both pilots we have the engine
indications for the two engines most
airplanes today have two engines just
because of redundancy if one fails they
can still fly on the other one but if
two fails like in this scenario you're
kind of in deeper trouble when faced
with a situation like this there are a
basic rule that all pilots in the world
know and that we have to follow
it's the aviate navigate communicate
rule so the first rule you need to do
before anything else is the a b8 which
means keep the airplane under control
that's the highest priority you have at
that stage after controlling the
airplane you need to continue
identifying the failure you have and you
work together as a crew to try to solve
this problem and then you need to
communicate tell a these-- air traffic
control that you have a problem and they
might be able to help you in some way
but what you have there and then is two
pilots flying an airplane and you just
need to work efficiently together to try
to solve the situation you're put in
[Music]
so we're seeing here that the captain
initially is trying to restart the
engine he also starts the so-called APU
auxiliary power unit if both engines are
failed the generator most likely are
failed as well which is empowering the
electrical system of the airplane but
the auxiliary power unit can supply the
electricity to the whole system if the
engines are failing this is a phrase we
use every day my aircraft on my controls
as soon as you need the pilot flying to
hand over the controls of the airplane
this is the phrase you are using so a
normal day at work we have the captain
in the left seat and the first officer
in the right seats at the beginning of
the day we decide who is going to be
pilot flying and who's going to be part
of monitoring for the each sector
throughout that day in this scene we can
see that the first officer is situated
on the right he has control of the
airplane initially but then the captain
decided I need to take controls I have
more experience try to manage the
situation in the best possible ways so
he's now doing the aviate part while
he's delegating tasks to his first
officer and then he calls for the qrh
which is a quick reference handbook the
Bible on board the airplane that is made
by the manufacturer with checklists for
the pilot to solve any problem with a
step-by-step procedure still focusing
and aviation navigates not communicating
yet because we haven't come to that
stage and the first officer is going to
start with that checklist
cactus 1549 birds we've lost thrust on
both engines we are turning back towards
the war hymn there we came to the third
step and now he has to communicate with
the famous phrase Mayday Mayday Mayday
you announced that you are in the
serious situation and that you have an
emergency on board the airplane once
you're declaring a mayday on the
frequency everybody around you ATC and
other pilots they know these guys have a
serious situation on board we need to
give them room to do whatever they want
and we need to move traffic away from
them and try to help them as much as
possible thrust levers confirm idle idle
airspeed left them to relay 309 we don't
have that in this scene we can see the
first officer together with the captain
is reading that checklist step by step
to try to realize those engines and get
them running again because they haven't
really seen outside how damaged Indians
are and you'll always try to restart
them especially at the low altitude like
this 1549 if we get a few you want to
try to land below my 1/3 we're running
but we may end up in the Hudson
so the air traffic control is set to the
captain would you be able to land on
runway 1 3 you can see that he's
thinking a lot he's looking outside he
sees the altitude they're at and he's
just saying we might end up in the
Hudson cuz he thinks worst case if we
cannot reach a field around here we have
to land somewhere and the only flat low
surface we have at this time is the
Hudson even air traffic controllers are
aware of the ab8 navigate communicate
like if it's quiet and the pilots are
not saying anything they wouldn't just
ask again and ask again they know that
you're flying the plane you're focusing
and solving the situation you're put in
and they don't want to stress you they
want to help you as much as they can but
they are aware that if you cannot answer
you're just busy with something else
cactus 1549 runway 4 is available if you
want to make web traffic to runway 4 I
don't think we can make any runway what
about over to our right anything in New
Jersey maybe Teterboro ok it's really
hard to say what a pilot can and cannot
do from air traffic control tower or
from a chair somewhere it's only the
pilots actually flying that feels the
plane they feel the wind they know the
weather the conditions they're in with
the flight experience that Sully had he
did the right call modern aircraft have
super sophisticated systems onboard
they've talked to you as you hear it
here they say obstacles obstacles
terrain terrain they even tell you
approaching runway 1/3 you are on runway
two three they communicate with you just
to give you information that can help
you during the flight wait 30 seconds
they're still trying to follow that loss
of thrust in both engines checklist
fighting until the end to start that
airplane and that's the thing you learn
in flight school you'll never give up
you'll always try to fix the situation
and you fight until the last minute you
fly that plane this is what they're
doing and it's beautiful it works like a
symphony and they're really doing their
part their task management is really
nice to see so on this frame here you
can see that there are 550 feet off the
ground so they're pretty low
and on the vertical speed indicator
there says they're descending as well
and their airspeed is 140 knots which is
quite low so they don't have much energy
in the airplane that cannot do much so
when seeing these figures I think he's
kind of taking that final decision is
there really no options available
anymore for him this is the captain
brace for impact so that is a pretty
scary thing to hear over the PA system
brace for impact I mean he doesn't have
time to call up the cabin crew and
inform them about the situation and the
cabin crew they know exactly what to do
when they hear this phrase and they'll
just strap in everybody start screaming
out the instruction for brazing go ahead
try number one
they'll be like we're gonna end up in
the Hudson they're probably done with
that checklist already they tried once
more nothing happens
that's when he realized they won't be
able to get any power out of those
engines they're totally destroyed and I
just need to line these hair playing
somewhere safe zone
as you can hear they're the air traffic
controllers are just giving them options
over the frequency this runway is
available you can turn here you can do
this and that's kind of their job and
just giving them as many option as
possible but the flight crew at this
stage has already decided to land to be
able to land on that River they want to
decrease the speed as low as possible so
the impact will be less the flaps are
the things at the back of the wing that
extends and increase the lift force of
the wing and that makes it possible for
the pilots to reduce the speed further
and land at the lower speed
we got runway two nine available at
Newark can be two o'clock at 7:00 mind
any ideas I told them they love this
they know exactly what to do one flying
one taking care of the checklist
they're trying everything to the last
minute I love that he's asking the first
officer is there anything else we can do
but they have done everything and the
guy says no I think we did it
so an interesting thing after this
accident we started practicing similar
scenarios in the simulator scenarios
with dual engine failures like this one
but also water landings
these planes are not meant to land on
water but they have a pressurized
fuselage which means that they're kind
of certified for floating for a while
even a couple of hours but only of
course if the fuselage is intact if it
breaks up or anything or the doors
failing they will probably leaking water
and eventually sink but if the fuselage
is intact you'll float for hours
so in the last scene there you can kind
of see them have that look like we made
it what now but as you probably know if
you've seen the movie Sullenberger is
going back to help the cabin crew with
the evacuation handing out sweaters and
pillows or whatever he's just doing a
tremendous work and he's the last one
leaving the airplane it is a really
beautiful thing to see
I really hope to meet him one day next
we have flight engine instruments are in
the green air speeds alive both sides it
looks like the weather's kind of rough
so before every flight to the captain
and the first officer are looking at the
weather both of the departure airdrome
the landing Airport and route weather as
well all airplanes have a limit and how
much crosswind they can depart in if
it's outside your limits you kind of
have to delay the flight or even cancel
the flight so you might stand there at
the airport have a look at the screens
and you see off the flights are actually
departing and half are canceled or
delayed this could be as simple as the
airplanes have different crosswind
limitations may be the bigger airplanes
they have higher crossing limits they
can depart and stronger wind but the
smaller airplanes they need to cancel
the delays we always want to start into
the wind so we want to head wind while
departing we can depart as well in tail
wind conditions but only performance
allows and there's a long runway and
whatnot but ideally is to start into the
wind that's because we get that extra
airflow over the wings that creates lift
and we can rotate earlier and climb out
of the runway with a shorter take of run
then if there were no wind or a tailwind
a crosswind comes 90 degrees from your
left or from your right so that gives
you controllability issues
30-knot crosswind exercises the old
indistinct the muscle this is kind of
unrealistic or very unprofessional I
would say because we load 10,000 feet we
have a rule called sterile cockpit we
keep all non-essential communications to
a minimum you would be focused on that
departure the takeoff roll and be ready
to control that airplane in quite busy
weather after departure obviously we
have a positive rate of climb which
means that we are climbing away from the
ground that's when we can select the
landing gear up once the pilot
monitoring is calling out to the pilot
flying the positive rates then he calls
gear up so they can climb away more
efficient from the runway
departure this is southjet due to the
seven we got some welcome shot by Sigma
if the pilot flying would like the pilot
monitoring to say something to a PC he
will just ask him like whenever you have
time could you please tell them that we
were experienced in this turbulence or
whatever you wouldn't just jump in on
the frequency take his job and just do
it yourself kind of unprofessional and
it wouldn't happen in real life
I'd say severe turbulence definitely
so he's reporting here to the air
traffic control that they're
experiencing moderate turbulence but
then definitely severe turbulence
turbulence is a common thing in aviation
we experiencing it every day at work and
we can kind of divide turbulence into
three categories light turbulence
moderate turbulence and severe
turbulence light turbulence is you kind
of experience it every flight it's just
when it's kind of bumpy the air is kind
of rough moderate turbulence is when it
starts getting really hard to like make
your way down the aisle things are
shaking and you should just stay in your
seat but severe turbulence is when
things in the cabin start to move around
you can see a bag going across the aisle
but another thing is that turbulence is
quite relative so if you have a small
airplane reporting severe turbulence you
might not even notice it if you're
flying in the Boeing 747 for example
which is huge jumbo jet you always want
to ask what type of airplane before you
reported the turbulence just to know how
to interpret that information so we go
back to the aviate navigate communicate
rule the thing he should be doing here
in severe turbulence is just to fly the
plane you wouldn't start going on the
radio reporting severe turbulence to
your traffic control like what are they
gonna do about it you can tell them in
ten minutes
what's going on like after departure we
experiencing this but doing it while
flying that rough air totally
unrealistic
I mean if my captors started doing this
I would definitely keep an extra eye on
it you don't behave like this your act
more professional as a pilot what are
you doing
leveling off what see that little sliver
of black between those two of
a pocket of smooth there's one right
over the center
thirty degrees you can see the weather
radar on the display there this is
actually something we check on the
ground while lining up for takeoff
before we even start rolling we let that
weather radar scan just to see if we're
able to follow the departure cleared
reaching by ATC or if we need to take
avoidance actions around severe storms
or whatnot on this screen you can see
different colors like we have green
yellow and red it is the intensity of
precipitation out there in the clouds in
front of you but he can kind of reflect
the turbulence as well the heavier
precipitation more turbulence you have
but you should definitely not fly in the
red and in this scenario he's trying to
find that heading here to go around the
clouds we would do the same but we would
have taken that decision way earlier on
the ground and help you now brother
you wouldn't just start praying in this
scenario as the first officer your job
is to make sure that the airplane is
flying within its limits so you would
inform the captain like we're not
keeping the correct speed we are way
above the limits we should do this
instead to keep us safe
Belem we're climbing
departure believe in matter thousand for
the whole one eight zero we have a
transponder on board the airplane sends
signals to the ground with all our
information so now the air traffic
controllers are calling like hey guys
you're kind of descending what's going
on you were supposed to climb away from
the ground because you want to climb
away from that weather approaching our
maximum airspeed damn right we need to
speed once do this practice so the
captain just said we need the speed to
punch through this crap that's a pile of
crap right there
you don't need speed for anything every
airplane has a designed turbulence
penetration speed both for the climb
cruise and descent phase so you wouldn't
just increase your speed to fly through
that rough air you would maybe even
reduce it to a speed that keeps you
within the flight envelope as long as a
way within that flight envelope
we are safe because we keep the airplane
flying within its limitations and
capabilities
now so he's saying we're experience some
severe downdrafts like it's throwing
down air with the rain and hail or
whatnot if you're flying below those
clouds you can really experience that
downdraft from above and you have hard
time climbing but this is a powerful jet
aircraft and he's not descending because
of those downdraft he's just trying to
do some cowboy maneuver pitching that
nose down to bring that speed up which
is strange and unrealistic so in this
frame right here and you see that he's
flying at 319 knots that's pretty fast
for any airplane at this stage I'm not
sure about this airplanes turbulence
penetration speed but in the 737 that I
flied you're in climb at low altitude
would limit the airspeed to 280 knots
maximum the job of the first officer at
this stage which actually be to take
control because the captain is doing
something that is unsafe but if you're
flying with the captain that has a lot
of hours and he's a very macho guy
doesn't admit when he's wrong and all
that and then you have this insecure new
copilot maybe just got his first job a
few months ago it could be very hard for
him to intervene with the captain's
decisions or even take control
unfortunately it can happen in real life
you can see that captain he's pushing
those thrusters even more forward
he doesn't mean he wants to go faster it
could also mean that he wants more power
out of the engines so he's pushing them
forward to maximum climb thrust if he
pitched his back then and bring the nose
up
he had more power to climb through that
turbulence in real life we would do this
we would climb at the turbulence
penetration speed with maximum climb
power on the engines just to get out of
there
[Music]
this is so Hollywood while you're in the
turbulence engine sounds are super loud
and it's very noisy and once you get
into the smooth air the end just gets
dead quiet and it's super calm that
wouldn't happen in real life they still
have that same client power on so the
engine would do the same sound in the
turbulence or outside
I've never experienced people clapping
like when you get out of turbulence we
do experience it occasionally after
landing if you do a smooth landing or
something and now airplane I've never
seen this movie it seems like we're
having a pilot in the control tower and
the only reason for having a pilot in
control tower would be to talk down
someone flying the plane and instruct
him how to land let's see what happens I
don't know if has any flying experience
but they're saying to him you're coming
in too fast like okay so if I'm not
flown a plane before what am I supposed
to do with it like the instructions he
gets are just like you know nonsense but
let's say you're coming in too fast the
thing you would do as a pilot is
probably to reduce that thrust you have
so it's not pulling you forward you'll
also have a speed rate you can use but
you normally don't use it this late in
the flight when you're a short final
approach for landing in real life we
reduce the speed way out far from the
runway and we have something in the
airplane called the final approach speed
this is the speed we need to have when
we're fully configured for landing all
the way down to touchdown if we're above
that speed you wouldn't just continue to
land
you would commence a so-called go-around
or missed approach when you throw those
trust Navis forward you get more thrust
from the engine's pitch the airplane up
and you get back up in the air just to
get configured in the right way for
landing once again sound your alarm bell
now
I mean we have a small button in the
overhead panel that we can ding the
flight attendants to get their attention
but there's no such thing as an alarm
bell and if this was a real scenario
where the pilots are incapacitated and
someone is flying the plane the cabin
crew in the back would be prepared with
everybody seated strapped in and taking
care of everything back there a long
time ago put down more flaps we do
extend the flaps in increments from
initial approach until the final
approach for example in the airplane I
fly we have flaps 1 5 10 15 25 30 and 40
so we have some steps there we can use
we normally use flaps 30 and flaps 40
for landings so that's the biggest flap
extensions that makes the wing as large
as possible to increase that lift and
drag as well to be able to reduce the
speed and get more stability for the
landing phase
[Music]
the approach light system that we have
in front of the runway is very important
for us it helps us identify where the
runway is you wouldn't just be able to
turn them off by a flick of a switch or
something like this there's very
important for the laning phase
especially in bad weather
[Music]
in this case he's all over the place
he's pulling the control column
everywhere in real life airplanes a lot
more stable than this you put it where
you want it you keep it there the
airplane will fly there may be small
Corrections after that but we always
strive to fly the airplane with small
smooth nice inputs so this is kind of
unrealistic as well it's fun to watch
[Music]
aim for the numbers aim for the numbers
and look at the end of the runway these
are kind of phrases that I remember from
flight school like in the beginning of
the runway you have always the runway
markers so for runway one three it would
actually say one three in big numbers in
the beginning of the runway so when you
start flying you're like super focused
on those numbers when they always say
aim for the numbers aim from the numbers
[Music]
okay first of all while landing the
airplane we don't up push the nose
forward we gently pull it backwards as
we close that thrust to reduce the
engine power so we have a nice nose up
pitching just before landing to get that
smoother kind of touchdown
to break you definitely not have like a
handbrake on your car like this
most brakes on airplanes today are
situated on the rudder pedals at the
floor so you actually brake with your
toes you push them forward to brake the
airplane
2:09 now
[Applause]
your gate at the terminal is not really
based on the landing distance you have
so if you do a longer landing the
passengers need to pack up their bags
and walk to a further gate that's not
how it works good fun though
[Applause]
this is normally how it looks like for
us when we were finding the simulator
we're sweating like crazy we call it the
sweat box that's when you actually
practice the hardest emergency
situations there are and we do it every
six months it kind of reminds me of that
but during a normal flight we wouldn't
sweat like that oh so he's halfway down
the runway and now he wants to brake so
he pushes those feet forward and starts
breaking the airplane but obviously the
airplane landing gear breaks up and
they're sliding down the runway that
wouldn't happen in real life because
landing gears are actually designed for
a braking
there are some accidents around the
world happened in the past where they
had some kind of hydraulic problem or
landing gear issues so they just had to
land on the belly of the airplane in
most cases as far as I know it went well
the fuselage and the engines and the
wing structure of an airplane are very
rigid and they can withstand huge forces
so it could happen and be like that in
real life last but not least
United 93 this sounds like a typical
pilot conversation you have when you
meet your copilot or your captain just
before work you always talk about were
you from what are you doing were you
living you talk about the weather
obviously because it's so important for
our jobs this is exactly how
communications between two crew members
would look like in real life you don't
always fly with people you know or
you're from the same place normally I
can fly with five different guys in a
week and they could be all from
different corners of the world even
though I've never seen the guy before
he's from another part of the world will
fly very efficiently together because
both of us are following the same
procedures the standard SOP which is
standard operating procedures we all
know a role in the flight deck we all
know what to expect from one another
this is how it looks like normally for
pilots around the world
so everything up to now looks exactly
like a normal day at work they already
set up and decide that the roles for
this slide so the captain is gonna be
the pilot flying and the first officer
is going to be the pilot monitoring so
in this case the pilot flying will stay
in the flight deck we will start
programming the GPS set up the whole
flight pic to be ready for departure and
the copilot his task is to go outside
and do the walk around or external check
just to see that all the parts of the
airplanes are working properly there are
no dents no damages or anything happened
during nights so he's just making sure
everything looks good from the outside
this is very typical as well you go out
there you chitchat with a fielding guy
and you also give him the fuel numbers a
few figures how much fuel you want for
that flight some people they already
call them in from the so called crew
room before and some they just give the
figures that a fuel in guy when arriving
at the airplane so how much fuel do we
actually carry on a normal flight flight
planning center since the pilots a
flight plan that says you're flying from
A to B you need this much fuel depending
on many different factors weight of the
plane cruising altitude of the plane if
you're a strong headwind along your
route you need to bit more fuel of that
if you have tailwind you'll fly faster
so you need less fuel it's also depends
on where your alternate airports are
located so if you're not able to land at
your destination when you get there for
some reason you need to be able to
proceed to an alternate field and if
you're flying to an isolated airport
where you have an alternate very far
away you obviously need more fuel for
that but whatever fuel the flight
planning center tells you to take the
pilots can always review that fuel and
decide to add some extra on it if they
see that there are thunderstorms and
route that they need to fly around or
turbulence at high altitude you might
get some extra fuel because of that as
well so you can cruise lower and still
reach your destination so it depends on
many factors but the flight crew has the
ultimate decision of how much fuel you
bring
so these lights are probably the landing
lights which are normally situated at
the root of the wings or just along the
wing so when you see the captain turn
them off again he knows that they're
checked by the copilot during the walk
around and they know that they're
working so if they don't need them
anymore and they'll just flick them off
they just received their ATC clearance
this is what you request on the ground
to get a clearance from air traffic
control on your initial routing after
departure initial cruising altitude as
well and that transponder code this
transponder it sends all the information
all the parameters of the airplane to
aircraft and control so later on they
can see on that radar display
United 93 and they also see the altitude
they're at their speed and so on so the
gentleman you saw there helping the
cabin crew close the door he's part of
the ground staff so he's most probably
the air bridge operator once they have
closed the door and the last passenger
has entered they're gonna move that air
bridge away to clear it from the
airplane so they can start their push
back the clip we just watched really
portrays a normal day at work and they
made it this way just to show that when
this all happened nobody expected it and
everybody was just going to work like
any other day unfortunately we need to
experience tragic events like this just
to be able to improve and make it safer
thereafter after 9/11 for example
procedures change for security at
airports they change for cabin crew
they've changed for pilots as well for
example who and when people are allowed
into the flight deck we also have a more
strict flight deck door closed culture
it has affected the aviation industry
quite a lot that was another breakdown
with GQ
watching
[Music]